[Musique]
samedi 25 mai 2e édition de voix en
scène au pôle musical bless Pascal à Man
les Hau de concerts 17h puis 21h on va
donc en parler avec vous audre brouant
vous en êtes là responsable coach vocal
également pour commencer je vous propose
si vous le souhaitez regardez un extrait
de l'édition précédente des imagees que
vous nous avez apporté l'édition 2012 de
voix en scène petit
extrait on onange
entité
métamorphose ce je aime assez pas
sou bien on se déoile
docteur
docteur si c'est
toi ce soir on change on change
l'identité m en PA ce jeu qu'on aimez on
est ass on a
ass c'était donc l'édition 2012 de voix
en scène prochain rendez-vous le 25 mai
à manie je vais vous laisser nous
présenter un petit peu le l'idée le
concept parce que ce sont des des
artistes en herbe des talents de de
mains qui se produisent en fait exact
oui donc le les voix en scène de cette
deuxè édition proposent en fait bah tous
les chanteurs qui prennent des cours au
départ on leur propose d'aller un peu
plus loin que de juste venir prendre des
cours de chant puisque laavie en scène
propose tout un coaching que ce soit
vocal ou scénique et cetera et cetera
donc on leur propose d'y aller d'aller
jusqu'au bout de ce travail là et
pourquoi pas de d'écrire leurs propres
chansons comme l'extrait qu'on vient de
voir c'était une des trois filles qui
pour l'occasion a écrit cette chanson là
pour toutes les trois euh donc on leur
propose vraiment d'aller jusqu'au bout
de faire ce travail de d'être accompagné
par des musiciens
de de de G audelà de leur salle de bain
c'est une association à la base agré
organisme de de formation des jeunes des
moins jeunes en tout cas des débutant ou
peut-être un petit peu moins débutants
qui vous rejoignent et que vous
accompagnez de A à Z voilà on accompagne
n'importe qui c'est ça n'importe qui que
ce soit un artiste ou que ce soit une
personne qui a juste envie de se faire
plaisir à chanter déjà il y a cette
partie loisir et ensuite les artistes
que ce soit des chanteurs que ce soit
des acteurs que ce soit des des des des
gens qui font du circle de rue donc on
accueille vraiment tout le spectacle
vivant et on leur propose donc un
accompagnement dans leur projet que ce
soit un travail scénique
d'interprétation un travail sur la voix
un travail sur le la l'image aussi avec
ben on a une styliste qui travaille avec
nous sur la communication comment faire
son pressbook et cetera et C donc c'est
vraiment très très large ce qu'on
propose certains début certains font
peut-être ça aussi pour s'amuser
plan des vraisjets professionnel
exactement comme Michel par exemple qui
a fait ben le trempelin les envol du
scabcou récment sur cette effectivement
page éta consacré voilà et donc bah elle
sera également là du coup samedi et elle
elle chantera deux trois de ses morceaux
avec les musiciens qui l'ont accompagné
sur l'envol pour elle ce sera un vrai
tremplin c'est une façon aussi de plus
en plus de se professionnaliser pour
d'autres c'est une récompense également
c'est ça elle a commencé
la première son premier sa première
scène sur le la première édition de des
vois en scèneer voilà sur les images qui
sont là il y a des des répétitions en ce
moment pour le concert du 25 mai on va
regarder quelques images que vous avez
réalisé également et puis on continue à
discuter ensuite de ce concert pas de
[Musique]
souci
the tell me how we so BL
to
the
[Musique]
pétition de voix en scène du concert du
25 mai à manie les amo les artistes qui
se produisent ont soit leur propre
répertoire les chansons qu'ils ont
composé eux-mêmes écrites également de A
à Z oui et d'autres font des reprises
c'est ce qu'on a entendu là ou c'est ça
donc reprise de un mélange St Wonder et
pastime Paradise puisque là sur la
partie qu'on a vu ce chanteur là a
proposé de mélanger les deux donc il
commence avec plutôt la version de
Stevie wonderer et enchaîne sur le rap
de pastam Paradise donc voilà parce que
c'est aussi ce qu'on propose c'est
d'interpréter et non pas juste de
rechanter le morceau comme l'artiste l'a
fait mais d'amener leurs propres pattes
qui se découvrent en tant qu'artiste en
tant qu'interprète qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
capable am à se découvrir en tant
qu'artiste justement comment vous leur
faites prendre conscience que qu'ils
sont des artistes déjà ça c'est par un
travail de de de prise de conscience un
travail sur
soi on les pousse un peu on les amène
làdans enfin il y en a par qu'il y a pas
que de la technique il y a aussi il y a
pas que du chant que de la technique
voilà c'est c'est surtout dans dans le
travail d'interprétation dans dans dans
dans l'accompagnement dans ce qu'on va
leur proposer on leur demande vraiment
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont envie de dire par
exemple à travers la chanson qu'ils vont
interpréter et c'est par là que ils
commencent à découvrir
vraiment qu'est-ce que quel est le sens
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont envie de donner et
dire et comment ça ça ça raisonne chez
eux la chanson qu'ils ont choisi en fait
et c'est par là qu'on arrive à amener
l'artiste enfin le chanteur l'élève vers
l'artiste qu'il est voilà on va dire ça
comme ça est-ce qu'il y en a qui
déchantent aussi c'est cas de le dire
mais est-ce qu'il y en a pour qui
finalement c'est c'est plus difficile
que prévu alors c'est toujours
aujourd'hui avec tous les concours qui
existent tout le monde s'imagine artiste
he oui exactement donc ce que ce qu'on
prend nous c'est de de de leur dire
surtout de pas se laisser faire par le
stress pas se laisser faire par je veux
que ce soit bien je veux machin
j'aimerais d'essayer de garder un pied
sur terre et de surtout c'est moment
pour se faire plaisir avant tout et que
ce soit à n'importe quel niveau où on
est avec n'importe quel enjeu je repense
encore à l'accompagnement de Michel sur
le le tremplin descarabé qui est un
tremplin qui était quand même assez
important c'est pas simple et il faut
ausculter tout tout ce côté-là et
pouvoir toujours ne pas perdre de vue
pourquoi on le fait pourquoi on a envie
de chanter et et voilà de toujours
garder ça en avant et et de B advienne
que pourra pour la suite quoi en fait
c'est un travail long vous VZ vousz
garder combien de temps avec vous là
c'est la deuxième édition du concert
ceux qui vont se produire sur scène on
vous ont rejoint quand au sein de
l'association alors il y en a qui qui
sont là depuis des années H qui sont là
même avant que bah la première édition
d'vau en scène a
apparu et puis il y en a qui sont là
depuis la rentrée il y en a qui sont là
depuis j apprennent vite alors il y en a
qui apprennent vite bah il y en a qui
apprennent vite oui puis en fait
l'objectif c'est c'est aussi qu'ils
arrivent avec ce qu'ils ont avec le
niveau qu'ils ont sur le moment et que
il y a pas
à aucun moment il faut il faut avoir un
certain niveau pour pouvoir participer à
cet événement là en fait ils arrivent
avec leur niveau et et ils sont
accompagnés par les musiciens c'est ce
travail de préparation qui va leur
permettre de de pouvoir faire ce concert
et puis puis voilà vous êtes coach vocal
on peut pas éviter de vous poser la
question li The Voice vous étiez venu
l'an dernier sur ce plateau au moment du
lancement de cette émission on l'avait
évoqué en long et et en large le show
musical de TF1 qui fonctionne avec des
coachs vocaux vous en pensez quoi parce
que vous faites un petit peu la la même
chose d'une certaine manière oui euh
sauf que cette année j'ai pas beaucoup
suivi à vrai dire j'ai même pas suivi
les lives j'ai commencé à suivre une
artisteinoise pourtant cette année ah en
plus qui s'est produite alors j'ai suivi
les artistes réignonnés j'avourais euh
c'est vrai que j'ai suivi les artistes
j'ai suivi juste le début en fait j'ai
pas suivi les lives j'ai regardé sur le
principe même vous trouvez
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas des des
formules qui sont à bout de souffle le
fait qu'il y a trop d'émissions pour
révéler des talents et que le travail se
fait aussi peut-être pas devant les
caméras mais aussi comme vous par
exemple sur des scènes dans des dans
dans une dimension encore plus humaine
et pas pas devant des millions de
téléspectateurs bah après la différence
avec The Voice c'est vrai que il demande
plutôt un niveau professionnel ou des
gens avec un avec soit qui sont déjà
dans le milieu donc qui ont un bon
niveau soit un excellent niveau de
technique vocale euh c'est différent des
autres on va dire qui eux qui ouvr par
exemple j'ai j'ai j'ai certains de mes
élèves qui sont passés à popst là il y a
eu donc ça va sortir
bientôt et c'est vrai que popstar c'est
un peu plus large on nous dit si vous
avez du talent allez-y tandis que The
Voice quand je reçois par exemple les
demandes pour The Voice on dit il faut
niveau professionnel ou bien une grande
expérience et cetera alors après c'est
surtout à ce niveaau-là mais en tout cas
la conclusion c'est qu'il faut mieux
passer par des structures comme les
vôtres pour faire ses preuves voilà
faire commencer à apprendre et à révéler
ça c'est important qu'il faut qu'il faut
pas pas sauter les étapes et le problème
c'est que les les artistes ont souvent
tendance à penser que il faut ben faire
des clips enregistrer pour pouvoir
réussir mais il y a quand même une bonne
part de travail qui ont travaillé seront
sur la scène de manilamo le 25 mai The
Voice et 8 millions de téléspectateurs
30 millions de recettes publicitaires on
vous en souhaite autant pour votre
concert du 25 mai on voit la fiche de
cet événement en partenariat avec Z bien
de association locale également merci à
vous